death is the enemy the first enemy and
the last everybody we got some new Game
of Thrones to break down the producers
have started to do interviews talking
about what's going on during the final
season what their original plan was
things that they've changed and
obviously production is still rolling
along it there are two big locations
they're gonna be filming all the way up
until next summer so for the time being
they're spending most of their time
shooting stuff at their Winterfell in
King's Landing adjacent sets although
the place where they're filming the
King's Landing stuff doubles for a lot
of other places too so it's not just
King's Landing scenes but if you are
finding me for the first time we're
doing Game of Thrones until season 8
gets here and then obviously book stuff
when the books drop so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm also still giving away copies of
that new george RR martin book i'll
explain at the end of the video too and
there is new Lord of the Rings TV series
stuff that I wanted to address but it's
not critical to Game of Thrones so
that's all so at the end of the video -
but as they've been making the final
season David Benioff has been doing
interviews talking about what their
original plans were and how some of the
things have changed along the way
so he said originally they knew about
90% of what the final season was going
to be like the big tentpole events that
needed to happen
so it wanted to do a video comparing
that 90% in the 10% because some of it
is actually pretty easy like we
obviously knew about the war with the
White Walkers but what is that 10% of
stuff that they had to make up
on-the-fly that George R Martin tried to
sort of help them with early on but I
think you're starting with the easiest
stuff we can start with the final war
with the White Walkers we always knew
that that was going to happen so these
are things like when they were sitting
down to plant season one that they knew
would be happening during the final
season the wall always had to come down
bran was always going to become the new
three-eyed Raven surprisingly the night
king was a relatively late addition they
didn't know everything about him when
the series first started because of the
way the book portrays the White Walkers
so the interesting thing is is that even
though George R Barton has a mythical
night's king that he's talked about in
the books
in present day there's no mention of a
night's king there's nobody leading the
White Walkers that we know of and if
there is George R Martin hasn't revealed
him yet
it's pretty easy to guess why the TV
show created the night King just because
people who don't read the books need an
enemy to focus on like oh this is the
bad guy that they're all trying to fight
who's leading this army of the Dead
it'd be kind of like Star Wars without
the Emperor or Darth Vader
it'd just be a bunch of ships blowing
each other up it'd just be like watching
a historical battle but we always knew
that Jon Snow was gonna learn who his
parents were what the ramifications for
the battle for the Iron Throne would be
you could argue this a little bit but I
think they always plan for Daenerys to
lose at least one of her dragons because
she's so overpowered with three of them
like there was always going to be a
moment where they were going to take
that away from her they always knew that
Jaime was gonna turn against Cersei that
was actually a pretty easy one even if
you don't consider the valonqar prophecy
he was always on this arc where he was
going to leave her and try to redeem
himself by helping fight the White
Walkers in the north John and Daenerys
Song of Ice and Fire were always going
to come together and unite everyone with
the exception of the people that are
still loyal to Cersei but I think the
idea there is that they always knew that
people would slowly abandon her until
the final season where she was literally
left by herself it's still up for debate
but there's a lot of stuff in the books
that have been pointing towards Daenerys
becoming pregnant again
we just haven't got to the book moment
where she's reunited with Jon Snow so
that's still wide open for theory
crafting but there's just a lot of
evidence pointing towards Daenerys
becoming pregnant again possibly with
Jon Snow's baby but the TV show has been
a little more heavy-handed with that
where she just keeps repeating over and
over again I will never have any more
children there was a witch that killed
my husband and my child that told me I
would never get pregnant again and even
Jon Snow remarking on that I'll serve
you well get children off to him
the dragons are my children they're the
only children Oliver when your family
hasn't seen its end I can't have
children who told you that
there weren't you murdered my husband
has it occurred to you she might not
have been a reliable source of
information so just think about them
plotting out the first season knowing
that eventually they would get Jon Snow
and Daenerys together and there's even
the rumours that behind the scenes
George are Martin was walking around the
Winterfell sets in season one saying
yeah you know this is all really great
but it's all about Jon Snow and Daenerys
but that sort of secondhand information
from one of the directors from season
one claiming that George are Martin said
something like that but whatever he
actually said was probably a little bit
different I can't imagine he'd be quite
so spoilery because he would have been
talking about moments and books that
hadn't been published yet and usually
he's really good about not spoiling
stuff that's happening in the future
when it comes to the smaller storylines
like cleganebowl I don't think that they
always knew they would pay that off in
the final season but moving on to the
10% that they said they had to create on
the fly so some of this is actually
pretty easy to guess out because you
have those relationships like the sand I
and grey worm things that will probably
never happen in the books so obviously
during season eight they're gonna be
spending a lot of time preparing for war
up at Winterfell and down at King's
Landing so some of those c-list
characters and commoners will be getting
scenes to sort of fill things out so if
you saw the casting video I did a while
ago one of the characters that they're
adding for season 8 is a sassy northern
girl who's gonna have a major scene with
the main characters and it's supposed to
be very memorable just to give the war
more human stakes so that it reminds you
in the audience what they're fighting
for
like they obviously we know all about
the mythology of the show but they also
have to get you to care about all the
common folk that they're trying to
protect even though most of the scenes
that we've been watching are these big
war scenes or scenes with the main
characters there's still millions of
people on the show that they're trying
to protect like they even talked about
the number of people in King's Landing
over a million people that could be
turned into the army of the dead they
have to get you to care about those
million people which is why they add
scenes with sassy northern girls just to
be like oh wow I like this person I hope
that they don't die most of the golden
company scenes are also probably brand
new to the show even though they had
this big storyline with the Aegon
character in the books he's not going to
be coming on the TV show so any
references to the books I'm expecting to
be at Easter Egg level like turns of
phrase lines of dialogue about their
implied history they're black by our
origins the characters that they cast to
be their leader doesn't look anything
like Daario so I'm not expecting them to
do a whole lot of book stuff with their
characters
it is they do it'll just be in very
broad strokes but then also that other
10% is probably the way they end the
series like they're probably been back
and forth about what those final moments
will be before they slander the credits
like are they gonna do it Lord of the
Ring style where they do this montage
and just jump forward and time showing
you what happens to each of the
characters or are they gonna choose to
end it in present day implying what the
future of the characters will be in then
go to the credits like no montage the
only thing that I am 99% sure that they
will not do is the soprano style ending
which we'll just call the middle finger
ending where they end without giving you
any answers about what the future of the
characters are there would be riots in
the streets if they did something like
that but speaking of the ending of Lord
of the Rings talking about that TV show
now if you didn't know there's a Lord of
the Rings TV series that Amazon is
producing they spent 200 million dollars
just to get the rights to make the TV
show so the budget will probably be
comparable with Game of Thrones budget
they haven't completely explained the
timeline but they said that it would be
a prequel and it would follow characters
that we haven't seen before
in the events leading up to the Lord of
the Rings trilogy so that just makes it
sound like it'll be set in between the
events of The Hobbit in The Lord of the
Rings so they can reference a lot of the
big middle-earth characters but for the
most part what you see will be new stuff
that you haven't seen before they
haven't said when they're gonna start
production who's gonna be the showrunner
which writers that are going to hire so
we'll probably find out about that next
year I'm not expecting to see any of
those episodes until 2019 it just sounds
like they're gonna try and dovetail with
the ending of Game of Thrones so the
people who really like that fantasy
genre are like okay Game of Thrones is
ending we need something else oh wow
there's a Lord of the Rings TV series
but also remember that there is the Game
of Thrones prequel but that probably
won't premiere till 2020 so when we find
out more about what's going on with
those series I'll just include that in
videos but leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below
there's a giveaway for that new george
RR martin book all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
the winner from my last video Elizabeth
please private message me so I can get
your contact details
you can click here to learn all about
the new characters that are coming to
season 8 and you can click here to learn
all about the episode schedule thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight